>> Hello, YouTubers.
This is Sergey, I'm here at Davos and have
lots of exciting
conversations here.
I just got this question I saw about voting
and what could we do to
improve it.
I think a really important part of voting
is to have a public that's
engaged and educated and really interested
in all the key issues as
well as the candidate positions.
And that's why I think that YouTube is a great
platform for that.
We started with the debates, having questions
come in directly from all
of you, but I think there's lots more opportunity
for engagement to
form greater communities around important
issues, so you're not just
getting little sound bytes but you can actually
delve deeper into these
issues and discuss them at a very deep level
with both experts around
the field and just many ordinary, interested
citizens.
So I'm a big fan of education and engagement
when it comes to voting.